[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها في
ابرز العناوين
حكومه طالبان تعلن مقتل مهاجم فندق
ولا ضحايا في صفوف المدني
ين والمانيا
مجلس النواب الليبيه يتعهدوا بمحاكمه
المطارطين في اعاده فتح ملف لقربي بتهمه
الخيانه العظمى وملاحقه من سلم ابو عجيره
تحذيرات من طقس قاص وثلث في بريطانيا
والجليد يعطل السفر في البلاد ومطار هيثرو
يلغي عشرات الرحل
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
اعلنت حكومه طالبان في افغانستان مقتل
ثلاثه مسلحين هاجموا الفندقا بالعاصمه
كامله
وقالت حكومه طالبان في بيان لها انه لا
يوجد قتلى في صفوف الاجانب المقيمين
بالفندق الذي يرتده عاده رجال اعمال
واكد مراسل العربيه ان الفندق الذي شهد
الهجوم يقع قرب القصر الرئاسي ومقرات
البعثات الدبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
متابعتها لهذا الموضوع معي من كابل الان
مراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر عبد الله
اهلا وسهلا بيت ملابسات هذا الهجوم ما
الذي كان يستهدفه تحديدا وهل تبنت اي
جماعه مسؤوليه حتى الساعه
اولا ااا لم تتبنى اي اي جهه مسؤوليه هذه
العمليه وهذا الهجوم
ويبدو من ملابسات وحيثيات هذا الهجوم وهذه
العمليه همم ان داعش ربما نفذ هذه العمليه
لان تم مقتل ثلاثه من المهاجين في
العمليات التصفيه التي نفذتها القوات
الافغانيه واا استمرت هذه العمليات
والاشتباكات بين الطرفين همم لساعات طويله
وانتهى بمقتل همم المهاجمين بحسب ذبيح
الله مجاهد الذي قال في تغريده بانها
اعداء الاماره بحسب التعبيره نفذ هذه
العمليه ويقصد باعداء الاماره داعش وداعش
كشفت عملياتها التفجيريه والدمويه في
العاصمه الكابل وكذلك في بقيه المدن
الكبرى وبالتالي القراءات سياسيه والامنيه
تقوم بان داعش هو الذي نفذ هذه العمليه
همم ونعرف عبد الله ما الذي كان يستهدفه
الهجوم يعني
هل الرعايه الصينيون الذين يرتدون هذا
الفندق كانوا هم المستهدفون من وراء هذا
الهجوم ام لا في مارب اخرى همم للمهاجمين
الصينيون المواطنين الصينيون كانوا ينزلون
في هذه في هذا الفندق بين حيل واخر والان
وصلتنا انباء للتبوي بان المستشارين الصين
كانوا قد نزلوا في هذا الفندق ومن الممكن
ان ااه العمليه التفجيريه استهدفت
المستشارين الصين والمواطنين الصين اذا
كنت اقول ان الصين في ال- في الاونه
الاخيره ابرمت همم اتفاقيات اقتصاديه
واستثماريه هائله مع طالبان وهذه
الاتفاقيه اذا ما نفذت على الصيغه المبرمه
ربما ستدر على طالبان اموال همم باهظه فمن
الممكن ان
المستهدفين همم يعني ارادوا من هذه
العمليه صرف الصيد من هذه المعاهدات
الاقتصاديه والاستثماريه مع طالبان بحسب
الذبيح الله مجاهد الذي اعترف بان الفندق
همم كان فيه اجانب ولم يصب احد من الاجانب
او لم يقتل احد من الاجانب الا
اجنبيين اصيب بعدما القيا بنفسيهما من
المنزل العلوي وهذا يعني ان في هذا الفندق
كان هناك اجانب صينيون طيب عبد الله لماذا
تبدو حركه طالبان عاجزه تماما عن وقف مثل
هكذا هجمات نحن نتحدث عن قلب العاصمه
كابول عن الشارع الذي فيه المقرات
الدبلوماسيه ومع ذلك هذه الهجمات تتكرر
لماذا تبدو حركه طالبان عاجزه عن وقتها
ولا تضع هذه الهجمات حركه الطالبان في
زاويه ضيقه
هذه الهجمات يبدو ان ان خلفها عقول مدبره
وان التكهن بها فضلا عن كشفها صعب جدا
وحركه طالبان يعني بين حين واخر تهاجم
معاقل لعناصر داعش والجماعات الاخرى التي
تصفها بانها اعداء الحكومه الحاليه ولكنها
لحد الان عجزت همم
تمنع ااا او
يعني تكون حيلوله همم دون هذه العمليات
التي تستهدف اماكن حساسه في قلب العاصمه
كابل وكذلك همم في همم في قلب المدن
الاخرى الافغانيه مثل ما زارت فكانت هناك
عمليات دمويه استهدف همم يعني علماء الدين
همم كانوا موالينا لطالبان ومؤيدين
لطالبان طيب
يسالك هل من الممكن ان يكون وراء هذا الهج
او المنفذوه هذا الهجوم كانوا يريدون خطف
همم بعض المستشارين الصينيين من اجل الضغط
على الحكومه الصينيه بفديه او ما شابه
اما الخطف من هذه المنطقه الحساسه
والخاضعه لنقاط التفتيش المكثفه من قواته
وعناصر طالبان فمستحيل واما مقتل او
استهداف المستشارين الصين فهذا ممكن ومن
الممكن ان هذه العمليه والهجوم المسلح
استهدف المواطنين الصينيين بما فيهم
مستشارين الصين بحسب اخر تقارير وصلتنا من
هذا الفندق علما بان المنطقه والشوارع
المؤديه كلها مسدوده لحد الان وتقوم عاده
القوات الامنيه بمحويه اثار مثل هذه
العمليات التفجيريه والهجمات التي تستهدف
مناطق حساسه ويروح لها ضحايا مدنيون
وغيرهم علم بان همم مستشفى الطوارئ في
العاصمه الافغانيه كابو الامريكي قال انه
تم نقل 21 شخصا من المصابين وثلاثه من
القتنه وهؤلاء القتلى مواطنون افغان هذا
الفندق انا رايته ينزل مواطنون افغان
وكذلك الاجانب بما فيهم الصينيون زيك من
كابول عبد الله نادر مراسل العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه المتابعه
الى موضوعنا اخر فقد ندنت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا لينا بيرفوض بالاعدادات في
ايران وقالت قبل اجتماع لوزاره الخارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الاعدامات محاوله من
النظام في ايران لقمع الاحتجاجات وترهيب
المحتاجين ومنعهم من القهر
واضافت الوزير الالمانيه ان العقوبات
الاوروبيه ستستهدف الحرس الثوري الايراني
بشكل مباشر
الاتحاد الاوروبي اكد دعمه لتطلعات الشعب
الايراني المشروعه نحو الحريه ونيل حقوقه
الاساسيه
وادانا بيان للاتحاد قمع السلطات
الايرانيه المنهج واستخدامها القوه
المفرطه ضد المحتاجين داعيا السلطات
الايرانيه الى وقف الاعتقالات العشوائيه
لاسقالات المعارضه
واذان الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا تنفيذ ايران
عقوبه الاعدام بحق المحتاجين وطالبا
باجراء تحقيقات مستقله حول حمله قمع
الاحتجاجات وفيما خص التعاون الايراني
الروسي اذن الاتحاد الاوروبي بشده اي دعم
عسكري تقدمه ايران الى روسيا بما في ذلك
المسيره واعتبرهم انتهاكا خطيرا لمبادئ
ميثاق الامم المتحده
وحضر الاتحاد الاوروبي ايران من عواقب اي
دعم عسكري اضافي الى روسيا وخاصه مساله
احتمال تزويدها بالصواريخ البالستيه وكان
بيانو الاتحاد الاوروبي ان ايران تواصل
نشاطات زعزعت استقرار منطقه الشرق الاوسط
من خلال تزويد اطراف حكوميه وغير حكوميه
بالمسيرات والاسلحه المتقدمه وان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه عازم على منع ايران من الوصول
الى سلاح نووي
مع من بروكسل لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه نور الدين فريد
النور اهلا وسهلا بك هل يستشف من بيان
الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا مؤشرات الى ان
العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وطهران
ذاهبه الى صدام مباشر ام لا المصطلحات
المستخدمه في البيان لم تخرج عن المالوف
الذين نعرفه
لا البيان بشكل اذا راينا تفاصيله في على
مدى الصفحات الست والنصف الصفحه
يفهم منها بشكل مباشر ان هذه العلاقات
ذاهبه في المزيد والمزيدي من التعقيدات
والصعوبات والعباره لدبلوماسي اوروبي يعني
اذا اخذنا على سبيل المثال الجزء المتعلق
بموقف الاتحاد الاوروبي من حمله القمع
المنهج والقمع في القمع الاحتجاجات في
ايران هناك عنصر اساسي ممكن ان يضعف هو هو
دعم الاتحاد الاوروبي الى همم القرار الذي
اتخذه مجلس حقوق الانسان بانشائي لجنه
تقسي الحقائق هذا القرار الصدر في 24 شهر
الماضي وان الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو ايران
الى التعاون الكامل مع هذه اللجنه وانه
يقول ايضا في بانه سيظل يتابعوا مساله
مساله المسؤولين الايرانيين عن هذا القمع
المنهج او القمع الذي على نطاق
لا نطاق واسع هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
هناك مساله همم وردت في البيان وهي همه
جدا الاتحاد الاوروبي يحذر ايران حيث ربي
يحذر ايران من تداعياتي تزويدها همم روسيا
بالصواريخ الباريسيه ذات الامد المتوسط
حتى وان كان همم امير عبد الاهيان اكد الى
جوزيه بوريل والكلام لجوزيل مساء الجمعه
من ان ايران لن تزوده ولكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتبروا ان تزويد ايران لروسيا
بالمعدات العسكريه خاصه المسيرات واذا ما
انتقلت الى الصواريخ الباريسيه يعتبر ذلك
تهديدا لامني وان ذلك ستكون له
تداعياتهم ما زال الثالث الاخرى تتعلق
بالاتفاق النووي حتى وان كان يعني الجميع
يعلم بان هذه الارتفاع يعني تقريبا انتهى
ولكن من الناحيه الرسميه الاتحاد الاوروبي
عندما نقرا البيان ان ايران لن تحت ابدا
على السلاح النووي هذه العباره هي العباره
الرسميه في البيان وان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يدعو المجموعه الدوليه الى تنفيذ القرار
الدوليه 22 31 بالكامل بمعنى او بما يوحي
ان هناك خطوات تسعيديه
يستعد لها الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما يكون
الوقت قد حان لي ان ينقل ملف ايران من
فيينا الى مجلس الامن وما يترتب عن ذلك في
هذا القرار من عقوبه يعني مدرجه يعني
موثقه في العام 2015 حتى ان كان في مجلس
الامن هناك دائما روسيا والصين طلب طيب
نور من خلال ما اشتمل عليه بيان الاتحاد
الاوروبي من مصطلحات همم هل الاوروبيون
منزعجون بالدرجه الاولى او اكثر يعني مما
يجري في الداخل الايراني منزعجون اكثر هم
من العلاقه المتناميه بين طهران ومسكو
اكثر مما يجري في الداخل همم الايراني
وتحديدا ما يحكى عن مساعده ايرانيه للقوات
الروسيه تحديدا في مخص الصواريخ البالستيه
والمسيرات بمعنى الاتحاد الاوروبي منزعج
من هذه المساله وليس مما يجري في الداخل
لا منزعج جدا حتى وان كان في هذا الانزعاج
لا اقول الشفقه وانما التضامن والتعبير عن
دعم ما يجري في ايران هناك نوع من الكلام
الذي يحيي به ان الاوروبيين ربما يتفائلون
بان شيء ما قد يحدث في ايران حتى وان كان
الحقيقه ان الدبلوماسينا لا يتوقعون ونقول
ذلك بحذر شديد وبتواضع لا يتوقعون سقوط
النظام يعني نقول في الامد الكريم لكن اذا
المقارنه هي بالاساس بين هذا الموقف
المتشدد اوروبيا تجائرا متعلق بالمسيرات
التي همم تقدمها ايران الى روسيا
بي انعدام الحماسه تماما والاشارات تقريبا
الغزليه على مدى سنوات للدعم الايراني او
تجاهل الدعم الايراني المباشر للحوثيين
بالمسيرات وبتكنولوجيا بالسيا هذه
المقارنه في تقدير هنا تاتي ازدواجيه
المعايير من ان الاتحاد الاوروبي في مرحله
ما يعني كان دائما والى حد البيان الذي
سيصدر اليوم ايضا هناك اعتبار لان
الحوثيين طرف في العمليه السياسيه الى غير
ذلك ولكن لم يتخذ الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات
ذات مغزى طب ما هنا دائما نور الدين اذا
كان الاتحاد الاوروبي ذاهب في هذا الاتجاه
يعني حتى التساؤلات على يعني بعض
المتابعين على تويتر لماذا لم تسحب اي
دوله اوروبيه سفيرها من ايران لماذا تبقي
على علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله لماذا لم تعلق
حتى تعلق العلاقه
هو يعني هو السؤال هل اذا قطعت دوله
علاقاتها مع طرف اخر بمعنى ذلك انعدم
الحوار انعمل عدمت قنوات التواصل ليس هناك
من غرام اليوم في اللغه دبلوماسيه
الاوروبيه في اتجاه ايران اطلاقا انما
هناك لغه عقوبات والعقوبات تعني العزله
الدبلوماسيه ولا اتصور ان دوله في العالم
ااه يعني تحب ان تكون في هذا الموقع مثل
موقع ايران او كوريا الشماليه بينما صحيح
ان الجينرات الايرانيين لا يقضون عطلهم في
الكوندايزر في جنوب فرنسا وانما همم يعزل
ان تعزل القيادات الايرانيه والمؤسسات
الايرانيه عن العالم عن العالم عن
المؤسسات عن التكنولوجيا فهذا امر مزعج
بالنسبه لنظام الايراني حتى وان كان هو
يظله او كوريا الشماليه
ال- ال- السؤال يعني الاجابه بايجاز اذا
قطعت الدول دول الاتحاد الاوروبي علاقاتها
معه مع ايران فما هي ستقطع ادوات التواصل
معها والتواصل ضروري ساكتفي بهذا القدر من
بروكسل مراسل العربي نور الدين شكرا جزيلا
لك نور على كل هذه المتابعه
في غضون ذلك قالت عائله الشاب مجيد رضا
نورد الذي اعدمته طيران صباح اليوم ان
السلطات الايرانيه لم تسمح لها بمقابلته
قبل اعدامه كما لم تسمح لها بالمشاركه في
مراسم دفنه واضافت عائلته مجيد رضا انها
تلقت خبر اعدام ابنها ودفنه في مقبره بهشه
رضا دون سماح لها برؤيته او التواصل معه
بتعليق المشانق للمحتاجين يجابيه النظام
الايراني لاحتجاجات الشعبيه الايرانيه
المتصاعده للشهر الثالث على التوالي مجيد
رضا رحمه ورد هو الثاني بعد محسن شكاري
الذي ينفذ فيه حكم الاعدام علنا في مدينه
مشهد شمال الشرقيه ايران لدعم قتله عنصرين
من قوى الامن الايراني
السلطات الايرانيه بخلفه
كان سبقه تهديد صريح من قبل رئيس اللجنه
القضائيه في البرلمان الايراني الذي توعد
المحتاجين بزياده عمليات الاعدام بحقهم ما
يمثل دليلا اضافيا وفق منظمه العفو
الدوليه على استخدام السلطات لعقوبه
الاعدام كاداه كمان سياسيه
منظمات الحقوقيه اطلق التحذيرات بخصوص
اعداد من الايرانيين وصفاتهم بالمعرضين
لخطر الاعدام الوشيك المرتبط بتظاهرات
قضاء النظام اعلن اذانه احد عشر محتجا
بالاعدام حتى الان
لكننا نشطاء يقولون ان حوالي 12 اخرين
وجهون تهاما قد تؤدي الى تسليط عقوبه
الاعدام عليهم خاصه ان النظام الايراني
يستخدم عقوبه الاعدام كجزء من حمله القمع
الوحشي بحسب منظمه حقوق الانسان في ايران
ومقرها اوسلو التي وثقت اسماء
458 شخصا على الاقل قالت انهم قتلوا على
ايدي قوات النظام فيما تشير الامم المتحده
الى ان ما لا يقل عن 14,000 شخص معتقلون
على خلفيه التظاهر لدى سلطات طهران حنان
المصري العربيه
لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا اذهب الى بروكسل
ينضم اليه من هناك انريك سيرفيتو وهو
الخبير في الشئون الاوروبيه سيد الامريكي
اهلا وسهلا بك هل العلاقه الاوروبيه
الايرانيه ذاهبه الى صدام مباشر برايك بعد
سمعناه اليوم من الاتحاد الاوروبي ام لا
اوروبا تنتقد ايران في العالم ولكن وراء
الابواب المغلقه تبقي على اتصالاتها بشكل
جيد مع السلطات في ايران
سيد امريكا هل تسمعني
سيد امريكا انت على الهواء مباشره هل
تسمعني
يبدو ان الاتصال غير مؤمن حتى الساعه مع
بروكسل لن اعود اليه فور جهودي على كلن
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه يتهم بوتين بشني
حرب غير مبرره ضد اوكرانيا
الجامعه في بلدنا فيها شيء ميزها يا سيدي
على لمه اهل الحجاز لقمه من تو على صفاتهم
ولا الحنين تحت غيوم الجنوب وسط جبالها
والله على صحن جديد اجمعنا في نجد الاحباب
وما تدري تمدح اللمه ولا المكبوس ما نسمه
هواء على بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعم المميز
حاضر معنا فيكي الجمعه الحلوه
[موسيقى]
هذه الدقيقه العسكريه لتوفير رحلات
الطيران اكثر اصطدام
اليكم مستقبل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاسواق العربيه في هذه الارقام على
الشاشه عربيه
[موسيقى]
المشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
دوران شديد يلعبوا قطاع السياحه في
الاقتصاد السعودي باصداف توفير مليون
وظيفه جديده وتسجيل 100 مليون زياره سنويه
في 2030 بحسب رؤيه المملكه اليوم وبعد
تسجيل 62 مليون زياره للمملكه في 2021
والمساهمه في اكثر من خمسه في المئه من
الاقتصاد السعودي فكيف يمكن للسياحه ان
تساهم بعشره في المياه وكيف تصبح السعوديه
وجهه عالميا السياحه السعوديه ضمن الاسواق
العربيه
اهلا بكم جديد اعود الى من قطع من حديث مع
ضيفي من بروكسل الامريكي سيرفيت وهو كبير
في الشؤون الاوروبيه صيدليتي ارجو ان تكون
تسمعني الان كنت قد سالتك منذ قليل هل
العلاقه بين اوروبا وطهران ذاهبه الى صدام
مباشر بعد هذا البيان الذي سمعناه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم ام لا ما تقوله
اوروبا في العالم هو غير ما تقوله وراء
الابواب المغلقه بحيث تبقي علاقاتها جيده
مع ايران
نوعي رومانسيه
في طهران
حسب علمي فا
اليرانيون ايضا قرروا
في اوروبا
وفيما يخصه وجهه نظر الاتحاد
حقيقه ان انهم يقومون باعدام المتظاهرين
من الصعب جدا
يعني همم
الايراني
باعدام
الايرانيين الذين يطالبون بالحريه
فالاجابه هي كلا لن تكون هنالك علاقات
الطبيعيه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي وايران
وحتى خلف ابواب المغلقه
هل تعتقد انه بمثل هكذا بيانات خطابيه
يمكن ان توقف ايران عن ملاحقه المعارضين
ام لا الامور تحتاج الى اجراءات اكثر
عمليا وليس فقط بهذه البيان او هذه الخطب
وين الان فورتنايت
وما يحصل داخلي ايراني
سيد امريكي
سيستطيع الاتحاد الاوروبي فعل الكثير
فودوره معروف يعني ونفوذه معروف في كثير
من المناطق في العالم تحديدا في الشرق
الاوسط يعني عوضا عن بيانات الشاجب
والتمديد تستطيع الدول الاوروبيه على
الاقل سحب سفرائها من ايران او تعليق
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه او حتى قطع العلاقات
وهذا ما لم يشهد كيف ترد على ذلك
نوتيلا
مثل هذه الاجراءات في المستقبل انت محقه
تماما الاتحاد الاوروبي بامكانه فعلا مزيد
على الصعيد الدبلوماسي اما من الناحيه
الفعاله او على ارض الواقعه فان النظام
طهران
مع روسيا عسكريا
وهذا يعني باننا نستطيع ان
نفرض عليهم بعض
التبعات فيما يخص الملف النووي الايراني
فلنرى ما سيحصل اما فيما
يخصاعده
الشعب الايراني والمتظاهرين في شوال
الايرانيه للاسف السعيده
ربما فقط المزيد من الجهود الدبلوماسيه او
الاجراءات الرمزيه
دمعه يعني يقول الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
سيستهدف الحرس الثوري الايراني او كيانات
وشخصيات قياديه في ايران طب ما هذا كمان
لا يسمن ولا يغني من جوع لان هذه الشخصيات
ليست لديها لا حسابات في اوروبا همم ولا
اصول في اوروبا وبالتالي كل هذه الاجراءات
لا تسمن ولا تغني من جوع على الاقل هذا ما
ما يحكى
صحيح
تماما ولكن
[موسيقى]
ان نتفائل ان تكون هنالك خطوات لعدم
تتبيعي همم
ما يجري في ايران ولكن على سبيل المثال
باي شيء نستطيع ان نفعله همم
موجوده اصلا وفرضت على ايران فمن الصعبه
همم
يقوم به الان
البوكسل امريكي سيرفيتو الخبير في الشؤون
الاوروبيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
طلب مجلس النواب الليبيه بمحاكمه كل من
تورط من الليبيين في اعاده فتح ملف لوكور
بيبي تهمه الخيانات العظمى واكد المجلس
انه سيلاحق عبر النائب العام كل المتورطين
في القبض على ابو عجيله مسعود كما اشار
مجلس النواب الليبي في ذات الصدد الى انه
حذر حكومه الدبيبه من الاقدام على
التسليمه متهما حكومه الدبه بالخيانه
العظمى لتسليم ابو عجيله مسعود
وفي سياق نفسه قال مسؤولون امريكيون من
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه ان مسعود ابو
عجيل المتهم بصنع القنبله المستخدمه في
هجوم الطائره بان امريكا اكد ان العمليه
صدرت باوامر مباشره من المخابرات الليبيه
وان القذافي شكره واخرين بعد الهجوم وفي
اواخر عام 2020 اعلنت وزاره العدل
الامريكيه عن توجيه اتهامات الى مسعود رغم
احتجاجه فيه فيما تعهد المسؤولون
الامريكيون والاسكتلنديون بالعمل سويه من
اجل تسليله وتقديمه الى المحاكمه ولم يفضح
المكتب الفيدراليه عن كيفيه احتجاز مسعود
لدى الولايات المتحده مشيرا الى انه سيكون
اول من يمثل امام محكمه الامريكيه وزاره
العدل الامريكيه اعلنت من جانبي ان مسعود
سينفل قريبا امام محكمه فيدراليه حيث
سيواجه تهمهتين جنائيتين تتعلقان بهذا
الهجوم
من طرابلس ينضم الي عبر الهاتف المتحدث
السابق باسم المجلس الاعلى للدوله الليبيه
السنوسي اسماعيل سيد اسماعيل اهلا وسهلا
بك حتى الساعه ما زالت ملابسات ما جرى
فيما يخص ابو عجيل الى مسعود غير واضح
اولا كيف تم سواء القبض عليه او تسليمه
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن من
مصلحته الان اعاده فتح ملف مع العلم انه
كان قيل انه في عهد النظام السابق شارع
اقفال هذا الملف تماما
المشاهدين في واقع الامر بالفعل هي قضيه
يفترض ان تكون مقفله ولا يعاد الحديث فيها
مجددا ولكن
الولايات المتحده فيها انقضاء لا يعترف
ربما باتفاقيات التي اجرت الحكومات
السابقه وانه ربما يحاول يعني كشف المزيد
من الحقائق حول قضيه
وهذا الاجراء التعسفي الحقيقه ضد الدوله
للشعب الليبي باختطاف ونقل المواطن ليبي
دون علم ال همم يعني همم
[موسيقى]
على الاقل كل الجهات الرسميه
والقضائيه والقانونيه لا تعرف شيء عن مصير
سيدنا من عنده
همم
بانه قد اختطفها من منزله من من اشخاص
مسلحين ولا ولا تعرف الى اي جهه ينتمون
لذلك اعتقد بانها الولايات المتحده الان
ااا ربما تحاول كسب ورقه جديده في يدها من
اجل الضغط على ااا ليبيا وربما الامر له
علاقه ايضا بالاقوال المجمده في الليبيه
في الولايات المتحده ربما هناك من يسيل
لعابه من اجل همم قرصنه هذه الاموال هذا
ما يعتقد في ليبيا على الاقل هو الراي
العام الحقيقه في ليبيا غاضب جدا من هذا
التصرف الامريكي الذي ينتهي في السياده
الليبيه والحقيقه همم كلنا الحقيقه لم
نكون نتمنى ان يكون هناك همم فتح همم جديد
لقضيه الوتر التي همم اقفلت منذ 23 سنه
تقريبا ولم يكن ولم وهمم جميع النفسيه هذه
رغم
وجود ربما معلومات جديده عن همم
متورطه ولكن كلنا نتمنى حقيقه فتح هذا
الملف الذي همم هذا الدوله الليبيه وهذا
الشعب الذي كثيرا فقط
همم استاذ اسماعيل معنى بيان اليوم بيان
مجلس النواب الليبي عم يتهم ليبيين
بالتورط في اعاده فتح ملف همم الاقربي
ويطالب يعني باسقاط تهمه الخيانه العظمى
على هؤلاء الليبيين من المقصود بهؤلاء
يعني هو طلب بمحاكمه كل من تورط من
الليبيين في اعاده فتح هذا الملف من من
الليبيين قد يكون متورطا برايي
هو في اعتقادي همم
يعني هذه المطالبه مجلس النواب فيها
مطالبه سياسيه يعني ما معنى كلمه خيانه
يعني ربما يكون هناك
وان كان هناك جهه رسميه في ليبيا همم قامت
بتفسيرها فعلا وهذه ربما تكون فعلا همم
[موسيقى]
ولكن همم اعتقد بان من السابق الاواني
توجيه التهم الى اي طرف اليه شخصيه لان
حتى الحكومه الدبيبه اعلى نفسنه سبق لان
قضيه مقفله وان وان ليس هناك
نيه طبعا هذا الكلام اتى على الانسان همم
وزيره العدل واللسان وزيره الخارجيه بان
ليس هناك اعاده فتح هذا الملف مجددا لكن
طبعا تعلم بانها منتهكه السياده حاليا
الامريكان الحقيقه هذه عرضه امريكيه جديده
على ليبيا
اعتقد بان التسرب على الطريقه ما كان
ينبغي ان يقوم بهذا الشكل يعني حتى لو كان
هناك ربما همم يعني القدر الامريكي يريد
المزيد من الحقائق عن هذه القضيه كان يجب
ان يتعاون مع النائب العام الليبي ومع
القضاء الليبي وان يحترم سياده الدوله
الليبيه وبصراحه الغضب كبير جدا في ليبيا
من جراء هذه السياسه الامريكيه برغم ان
هناك جهود كبيره تقوم بها وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه من اجل تحسين همم صوره همم
الولايات المتحده المشوهه كثيرا في ليبيا
باعتبار ان همم ربما امريكا في وقتنا
الاوقات يعني مارست همم حصان يعني غارات
الجويه على ليبيا وهمم يعني هذا غير طبعا
الصوره العامه
يفتح العلاقه الليبيه الامريكيه على نصره
عليها من جديد هذا واحد اثنين هل يمكن
يعني انطلاقا من بيان مجلس النواب ليبيا
الجزم بانه في اطراف ليبيه هي من قبضت همم
القت القبض على ابو عجيله همم مسعود
وسلمته الى المخابرات الامريكيه
من السابق الى وادي بين الاسره السيد ابو
جيل ابلغت عن انه قد اختطف من قبل
المسلحين مجهولين والى الان الذي يتم كشف
حقيقه كيف تم اختطافه وكيف تم تسليمه برغم
ان اسره همم
اعلى
ناسود باطلاق شراعي في اقرب وقت ممكن ولكن
تفاجاوا الحقيقه بعمليه همم
بهذا الشكل يعني كانهم عن النيه سيئه
ربما مبيته همم توريد الدوله الليبيه
مجددا طبعا هذا طبعا
همم
السابق رئيس المجلس الاعلى الدوله الليبيه
السنوسي اسماعيل شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشكله
عشان وزير الخارجيه البريطاني على رئيس
روسي
اوكرانيا تتناقضوا مع القانون الدولي
بالعمل على اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا وحفظ
الامن في اوروبا
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن طلاقه من استنزاف
ترسلته العسكريه بسبب استمرار الحرب في
اوكرانيا
الدفاع الاوروبيه من دول الاتحاد تكثيف
العمل الجماعي لرفع مستوى القدرات
العسكريه وتجديد المخزونه
قلق اوروبي مع استنزاف المخزون العسكريه
في الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
وقدراته اوروبا الدفاعيه ربما لن تحميها
من التهديدات وفقا لمنسق الشؤون الخارجيه
والسياسه الامنيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
حرب اوكرانيا بمثابه جرس الانذار لقدرات
الاتحاد الاوروبيه العسكريه وهشاشه سلاسل
الدوري
لكن ماذا انفقت اوروبا على الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه تتحدث عن
ارتفاع حجم الانفاق الدفاعي داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي في 2021 الى 214 مليار يورو
زياده الانفاق الدفاعي تعادل 6% مقارنه
بعام 2020 كذلك زياده الانفاق تشير الى
اقوى معدل نمو منذ 2015
تقرير وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه اشار ايضا
الى حجم الانفاق الجماعي الاوروبي على
عمليات البحث والتطوير لدول الاتحاد
انه بلغ 248 مليون يورو خلال 2021
بعد سنوات من الانخفاض معدل النمو قرب
السبعين في المئه مقارنه بعام 2020 نصفه
لمشاريع البحث والتطوير
انفاقه
464 مليون يورو اضافيه للوصول الى معيار
البحث والتطوير للدفاع التعاونيه الاوروبي
بنسبه 20%
المطالبه بسد الفجوات الحاليه في القدرات
بشكل سريع لتجديد المخزونات وتحسين
الاستعداد القتاليه
هو رغم ان مستوى الانفاق على الحرب في
اوكرانيا ربما تجاوز سقف التوقعات الا ان
دول الاتحاد اتفقت على دعم اوكرانيا
سياسيا وعسكريا واقتصاديا حتى تتمكن من
طرد القوات الروسيه من اراضيها جاسم محسن
العربيه
في مدينه جنوب شرق اوكرانيا المستعر حولها
القتال قام متطوع بالعزف على بيانو داخلها
كان رئيسها المدمر
[موسيقى]
مستمره وفيها ايضا
صوره لي بطاقه الميلاد للملك ان شاء الله
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه حذر مكتب الارصاد الجويه
البريطاني من مواجهه الطقس قاسم بسبب
استمرار تساقط الثلوج بشكل كثيف في انحاء
البلاد مع انخفاض درجات الحراره ما تسبب
في اضطراب حركه الرحلات الجويه في اجزاء
من البلاد فيما الغى مطار هيثرو اكثر من
50 رحله جويه بسبب كثافه الضباب وانعدام
الرؤيا كما تسببت الظروف الجويه في اضطراب
حركه القطارات ووقوع حوادث على الطرق
السريعه
هذا يواصلوا عماله نقاد البحث في بحيره
ويست مدد في وقت متاخر من مساء الاحد وسط
مخاوف من احتمال وجود اطفال اخرين سقطوا
في البحيره ولا يزالون في عداد المفقودين
وكانت فرق الطوارئ قد انقذت اربعه اطفال
بعد سقوطهم في البحيره بسبب تكسر الجليد
تحت اقدامه
[موسيقى]
قبل مراسل العربيه في المغرب مجموعه من
الاصدقاء وجيران النجمه المغربيه يوسف
النصيري في الحي الذي نشا فيه بمدينه فاس
حيث اعرب له عن فخم واعتزازهم بابن حييهم
الذي قاد المغرب الى بلوغ المربع الذهبي
لكاس العالم بعد تسجيل هدف الفوز امام
البرتغالي
لاعب كبير
الهداف تاريخي ديال الفريق الوطني
هداف تاريخي ديال جوجكو كاس العالم 2018
والحمد لله يقدر يوصل العالميه
بفضل مجهودات ديالو الكبيره
بالنسبه ليوسف الناصري ماشي ماشي صاحبي
ولا ولد حومتي بل هو خي الصغير
[موسيقى]
نشر قصر باكينغهام صوره لبطاقه عيد
الميلاد الاولى للملكه كاميرا
نشاط الخامس المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]